[Musique]
vous connaissez mes amis dont vous allez
adorer costume avec des baskets très
chic
tu te fous de moi non mais regardez qui
voit la vanne club de julio iglesias
et montrer à celui qui est un de match
c'est bon je vais j'y vais c'est mon
fils croyez moi en fait une bonne équipe
rami situé au risque à courir ou pas
vous connaissez miami non vous allez
adorer
c'est beau les français oui de
belleville ravi de vous rencontrer chez
nous tu n'es pas un vrai flic toi tu es
là pour obtient ce que t'es dingue tu es
fou de moi ou quoi
donc j'ai pas loin d'avoir hagen du
livre ont interrogé des témoins ou
profiter qu'est-ce que je peux faire
alors rien du tout
boucler une voiture mais n'ont pas
traîné go c'est là ma voiture c'est ça
ta caisse même deux flics à miami on va
pas le faire en fait